Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two. David P. The Egg Man
calling in with a very fair question about the
entire Kyle Rittenhouse trial. He's he's very
much on point here. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: How long before Kyle Rittenhouse
is on the Joe Rogan podcast, getting four hours to
cry his whole story out to America? You think Joe
Rogan is foaming at the mouth to get him on there
right now, chomping at the bit? You know he is.
Speaker 1: Shalom, Eggman. Yeah. Noah. This
came up yesterday during our live stream of
the Rittenhouse jury verdict watch. I think that
so Rogan recently had on. I believe her name is
Amanda Knox, the woman accused of killing someone
in Italy. I believe it was and subsequently
acquitted. And I think that Rittenhouse, they're
going to make this kid a hero or a martyr. It's
a win for Rittenhouse is. Either way, he's going
to be lionized either as a hero or as a martyr, as
a hero of self-defense, or as a guy who martyred
himself to help people and all this other stuff.
And now is, you know, had to suffer consequences
unfairly one way or another, this guy is going to
be a hero. And it would not shock me even a little
bit to see Rittenhouse on the Rogan podcast,
telling the whole story and being further held up
as a hero by the vast majority of the people who
hear it. Well, we'll keep an eye on it, right?
I mean, it'll depend if he ends up having to go
to prison for a while, it'll be different.
But we are standing by for that verdict.
The Republican Party already has enough safe
seats to win back the House in 2022 through this
redistricting alone. This is a story that is not
being told enough. We're going to talk about it on
today's bonus show. Number two United Airlines,
after a big, big hiatus due to the pandemic,
is resuming sales of hard liquor. This can only
go poorly, I think. And we are going to talk
about Bernie Sanders being a No. On the Pentagon
budget budget vote seven seven 778 billion for
the Pentagon budget, Bernie is a no. We will talk
about that and more on today's bonus show. Sign up
for the bonus show, folks. Don't miss it. Don't
miss it. Join Pacman dot com is the place to go.
Sign up today and we will see you on the
Unidentified: bonus show in the next.